[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
factors at some point every living thing
we see around us today is going to die
in decay
including you which is a pretty dog way
to start a phone but base to faceless
factor other than pretend we will all
live happily ever after war violence
hatred greed racial and social conflicts
animal cruelty environmental abuse it's
a part of everyday everywhere it is a
sad tale indeed our world is for us to
change to rescue a nurture and protect
for our happily ever after to exist and
for the next generations too so here's
another fact there are many good people
out there who do you care giving of
themselves and doing greatness
these unsung heroes who are not big
enough nor sensational enough for the
mass media to care about he notices them
I'm dedicating my channel to those
people to give them a voice rather than
be drowned with images of fake people
molded by the media all news about how
hollow we human beings are and how badly
we treat everything and everyone I want
to tell stories about those who
genuinely care ordinary and selfless
people doing wholesome things every day
no matter how small the individual
effort may seem they have great stories
and the impact is big within their own
cause a great big story is helping me do
this by supporting my journey around the
globe in search of epic stories to
showcase the many many tiny lights at
the end of a pretty vaguely dark tunnel
the more amazing moments I see the more
hope I have the world is world with way
more awesomeness than we know and
hopefully I can share many of these
stories with you like this one we're a
group of locals on a tiny island of
Zanzibar the east coast of Central
Africa are completely unaffected by
Media and daily negative information but
realized on their own that change was
necessary and that was up to them the
beautiful green back Turtles used to
live on the shores of Sciences are read
and lay eggs right in front of the
locals the increase in tourism
slowly created a need for more food the
fisherman had to increase the size of
the nets in order to catch more fish and
in turn started catching the sea turtles
too
[Music]
slowly but surely people from the
community started noticing a decrease in
the amount of sea turtles on the shorts
of their beaches as well as in the
oceans then without the help of any
outsiders the group of locals started
conserving them by means of education
through the schools and in the villages
bringing the green back turtles back to
its natural state does this not start to
enlighten your faith in people
a small community completely restoring
the life of greenback turtles on their
shores for the sake of the better future
world head over to great big stories
channel to watch the full phone we've
created I hope that you enjoyed it and
please let me know what you think in the
comments below
I really want to carry on sharing these
stories with you so please help me by
spreading them as much as you can to
make our planets a happy place full of
hope see you guys in
[Music]